a queen fall but scarlet on the regroup
is
in many ways Starcraft gave birth to
eSports as we know it from literally
being launched into space to drawing
thousands of rabid fans to arenas it was
a legit eSport before the word was even
invented in terms of the sheer number of
participants the coverage and the money
at stake
Starcraft used to be the biggest eSport
on the planet but now it's hard to feel
like it really even matter so what
happened
what toppled the king of eSports to give
you an idea of just how huge Starcraft
was 120,000 people showed up to watch
these Starcraft Sky Pro League finals in
2005 that's 40,000 more people than were
in the arena for the Super Bowl that
same year meanwhile this year Starcraft
streams were lucky to even hit 85,000
people and has for people watching from
the comfort of their own home but to
understand why Starcraft fell we have to
understand what made it so great in the
first place when brutha word came out
about a year after StarCraft I came out
the game became really really popular in
Korea so popular that even people we
didn't play computer games knew about it
and they even knew about the best
players who they were because they were
on television so much back when gamers
were still considered basement-dwelling
losers in the West Pro Starcraft gamers
in Korea were revered as God Gooding a
taxi coming from the airport and there
was a poster and I think it was a box
advertising something or other and you
know I think I made some sort of remark
and the taxi driver then proceeded to
tell us that he was training to become a
professional gamer and this guy was
probably in his 60s and yet here he was
you know going down to the LAN cafe
dirty seat bangs every other day after
work to practice football and it was
only then I suddenly just went okay this
is kind of crazy [ __ ] this is way bigger
than it is in the West the best of the
best were given the title bone drop a
title that came from holding the love of
the people not just drive statistics and
records and in Korean Starcraft matches
were broadcast on
television and eventually spawned entire
channels dedicated to broadcasting the
game Korean Starcraft teams were even
sponsored by corporate giants like Korea
Telecom and South Korea Telecom so what
happened was is these PC bangs sprung up
all over Seoul and all over Korea which
allows players to go in and spend free
time at very little cost on high-quality
pcs of the time anyway and they all came
preloaded with Bruegel so suddenly
you've got all of these things combining
TV looking for you know new stars sports
people looking for new sports stars
brands looking for young males in
particular but also women to advertise
their products and here comes this
massively popular free effectively free
game that people can play in PC bangs
and so it was a perfect storm all of
these things combined to allow Starcraft
the Blue Boar in particular to just rise
up out of nowhere and within a couple of
years they had TV stations devoted to
the to the games and to the leagues by
the mid-2000s Starcraft had a fully
built out eSports infrastructure in
Korea one that was used as a model for
the West but Starcraft got so big so
fast that there was a little room for
growth by 2006 Starcraft hadn't been
patched in five years which is insane
given how often games get patched these
days as far as the Starcraft community
was concerned the game had been figured
out there were no more new moves to make
no more new strategies to develop that
is until Jaedong showed up
[Music]
Jayden's rivalry with flash the greatest
Starcraft player of all time revitalized
the game with these two you don't need
qualifiers these are actually just the
greatest gamers ever but at the end of
the day they were still playing a
decade-old game the Starcraft community
needed something new it's about time
Starcraft 2 wings of Liberty was the
beginning of a new chapter for the game
slowly but surely it pushed broodwar out
of the competitive arena and for a few
glorious years Starcraft 2 was the
biggest eSport in the world
war was
time the boy race come out
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
unlike broodwar wings of Liberty was
bigger than just South Korea Starcraft 2
was unstoppable
at least until heart of the swarm
happened part of the swarm was Starcraft
2 his first expansion and any hype of
the community hadn't going in was
quickly deflated by a pretty severe drop
in game balance the big problem were
swarm hosts a zerg only tool that could
basically spawn infinite units without
the need for gas or minerals the swarm
boasts I think it's the worst thing to
come to Starcraft 2 and if all that is
gibberish to you all you really have to
know is that swarm host were broken I I
don't think he has any plan I've lost
all comprehension of what he could do
from here there is no answer
I really feel there is no answer
warmouth meant that every Zerg player
just wanted to slow the game down to a
crawl and who could blame them
if it worked they were gonna win the
game g5k takes game number one and he
knew that for a long time as did we but
in the end
patience wins out and sure there was a
cool match every once in a while but
most people were complaining that
Starcraft just wasn't fun to watch
anymore this game is not the most
entertaining game we've ever seen to say
the least they all played exactly as
they should be they're playing as they
should be if they want to win I don't
know if the viewers would agree this is
how they should play and Starcraft
popularity began to wane more and more
players began to retire I am NOT going
to continue as a competitive player it's
just gotten to the point where
competition is not enjoyable for me
anymore fan favorite Stephano
for example JumpShip live on stream the
reign of Stephano
has come to an end that is an end of a
very special era for that young man
there he's accomplished so much in his
Starcraft 2 crews been the guy he's been
the player he's made a lot of money
playing Starcraft 2 he's not enjoying it
as much as he used to by 2015 other
games have risen up to take Starcraft's
place in the eSports world part of the
swarm crippled the game but lizard was
hoping that their next expansion could
revive it do you think maybe you'd like
to see the void has legs do we feel like
that's the case absolutely I think the
biggest question will be how much and
and for how long it's always gonna be
one of those top five games over the
next few years Blizzard tried to make
the game faster to bring it more in line
with a Starcraft that everyone fell in
love with but their next decision with
the final nail in StarCraft coffin in
2016
Blizzard a region lock Starcraft 2
tournaments that meant that Korean
players could only play with other
Korean players in Korea for tournament
purposes it was supposed to introduce
some regional diversity into Starcraft's
pretty Korean dominated competitive
scene
[Applause]
well championship series Europe champion
what Blizzard didn't anticipate is that
it created a sort of vacuum in South
Korea all over the new up-and-coming
South Korean players could now only play
against the veterans who've been
dominating the game for years yeah I
think it's it's definitely unfair right
on an individual level
Koreans are subjected to a different set
of rules and foreigners much stricter
set of rules like intuitively that will
just strike a lot of people as being
unfair in general as the Korean skean
has progressed the Lord's here and
mid-tier players have kind of all
dropped out whereas the top tier players
are still playing without new blood the
came stagnated then sponsors began to
drop out moving on to more lucrative
games like League of Legends dota and
csgo well here that year pro league
dissolve it was the longest-running
league in eSports history Korean players
are not improving at the same rate as
they have because the team house
structures have collapsed they have less
support in that aspect they're all
living on their own essentially and
there's a lot less collaboration within
the Korean scene as there used to be the
other problem of course is that
real-time strategy games like Starcraft
just aren't that popular anymore they're
fast paced and complicated and they
don't really lend well to a pleasant
viewing experience for a newcomer
diehard Starcraft fans stuck it out and
the scene isn't without its bright spots
the game still has a following all over
the world with nostalgia keeping the
grandfather of all eSports afloat but
there's still that nagging what if what
if Starcraft didn't fail and what if
anything could bring it back to its
former glory in 2017 Blizzard made
StarCraft free-to-play and they
introduced the war chest a crowdfunding
initiative that attempted to make the
eSport more valuable but Blizzard can't
turn back the clock the fans are
dedicated and the game is still great
but it'll never be as huge as it
was Starcraft will always be the
granddaddy of eSports but its glory days
are over thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages